Alex Moffat: Good afternoon.
My name's Alex Moffat,
and this is Damon Lundin,
and we're going to talk
about our experiences
building Lombardi Blueprint
with "Gwit"
or G-W-T as I should now
pronounce it.
So this presentation
includes some examples,
and you can download
the code for the examples
from our blog
development.lombardi.com
so you can actually run them
and don't have to worry about
trying to read a couple
of lines of 18-point type
and make up the rest of it.
So a very quick slide
that Damon is gonna talk to...
but before we get to that,
who here has got GWT code
running in production
at the moment?
And...who's experimented
with G-W-T?
Great. Thanks so much.
So quickly, please.
Damon Lundin: Okay,
so I guess I'm gonna
go through this very quickly.
We weren't sure what the level
of experience was gonna be,
but basically, I think pretty
much everyone in the room knows
that GWT is a toolkit
that allows you to create
a JavaScript application
written in Java.
The obvious advantages are
you can use all your favorite
Java tools
like your development
environments,
your debugging tools,
your testing tools,
things like that,
handle some of the differences
between different browsers.
You still need to know
some things.
GWT can't cover over
everything.
But there's some differences
that it can take care of.
One of the things
that you may not be aware of
that is one of
my favorite features
is the optimization
of the GWT compiler.
The GWT compiler is capable
of doing optimizations
like method inlining,
string interning,
and a whole host
of other things
that you wouldn't normally do
if you were writing your
JavaScript application by hand.
So even if you were writing
your application by hand,
you're still not likely
to produce code
that is as efficient
as what comes out of
the GWT compiler.
For those of you who are
experimenting with GWT
or have an existing
JavaScript application,
I also want to make
the point that
you don't need to worry about
trying to use GWT
with that existing code.
GWT can integrate
with existing JavaScript
libraries or code,
and it can peacefully
coexist with that code.
The application that we're
gonna show you here today
was originally written
in JavaScript
using the Dojo Toolkit.
And when we decided
to use GWT,
all of our new features
were implemented using GWT
and over a period of time,
we slowly migrated
the existing code--
the existing JavaScript
code we had into GWT code.
It was not something
that we had to do all at once.
So I think that's an important
point to make.
So Alex is now gonna show you
what we've done with GWT.
Moffat: Right. And what
I want to talk about really--
what I'm gonna try and show
is the UI
more than any particular
features.
So this is the home page
for Lombardi Blueprint.
We have a list
of what's happened today,
and I'm gonna look
at a particular project
and then look at a map
of a process
within that project.
So...this is basically
the outline
for what you would do
if you wanted to give a talk.
So at the moment,
I've got some sorts
of things I'm thinking about
like I need slides,
I need to do an abstract,
I probably need to rehearse.
We got some travel
I got here...
Now I can...I can do things
like...
the abstract should probably
be before the slides.
I need...let's make the slides
actually part of that.
Let's do hotel and travel...
and then print.
You know, I need to...
I need to submit this thing.
So we've got here
is basically drag and drop.
This is all JavaScript.
I can move things around.
Stuff rearranges.
We've got some animation.
Panels fly in and out.
Different views appear.
It's all fairly fancy.
It's all done in GWT and HTML.
Got things like expanding
and collapsing panels...
and I just wanna point out
this bit down here at the bottom
'cause we're gonna
come to this...later.
So what I want you
to get out of this
is this is a sort of look
that we have for an application.
It's not like an Eclipse Style.
I have, you know,
a tree on the left
and a bunch of forms
in an area on the right.
Because what I actually
want to talk about
is how we do UI development
for that sort of UI.
How do we go about
building that sort of thing?
And the first...
probably most important point
is it really--
it's based on...
a foundation of everybody
in the team
really has to feel that
it's a big part of their job,
the most important part
of their job,
to create a great
user experience.
'Cause Blueprint is really
all about the user experience.
People have really got
to enjoy using this tool,
because otherwise they can
just cancel their subscription
and stop using it.
It's much more of a voluntary
sort of thing
than apps that, you know,
you're going to force
hundreds of people across
the organization to use.
We have two user experience
user interface designers
working on Blueprint.
And they take...
the market requirements
from product management
and are responsible
for producing
the visual realization
of those,
so how are we actually gonna
present these features
to the end user?
And of course,
it starts with a white board.
So you work out, you know, what
assumptions are you gonna make,
what are the use cases,
what are the various
process states?
Let's draw some things
on pieces of paper
and stick them on the wall
and annotate them
with sticky notes...
and then move on
to the next stage
of producing
some quick mockups,
some wireframing
in Illustrator.
And at this point also,
you can go out to users
and potential users
and test the interface
as it is now.
Are the features
readily discoverable?
Does this actually present
in a reasonable way?
And this is also a...
a point where
the programmers can say,
you know, that feature there
is really gonna be incredibly
difficult for us to increment.
Can you think of
another way to present it?
Just as important
is mocking up the interaction.
And this is partially
still an open question for us.
We've used PowerPoint
or Keynote to present the flow.
So I click on this button here.
I wanna switch to another slide
showing the next screen.
We're investigating a tool
called iPlotz
that is an online way
of presenting...demos.
But it is important to...
to be able to mock
the interaction up cheaply
at an early stage,
rather than require everyone
to write the GWT code
and then say, you know,
"I want this panel to slide in
instead of slide up,"
because that's gonna change
the way in which
we actually do our layout.
Then the final stage of this,
of course,
is the high fidelity mockup.
These are more expensive
to produce
'cause it takes them
more time to do it,
and these are done
in Photoshop.
At this point, again,
we're testing...
is this the right color choice,
is this the right look?
And also,
it's great documentation
when you're programming,
if correctly annotated
with what are the font choices,
what other colors
are involved here?
The UI people also give us
all of the assets that we need,
so all the nice
rounded corner bits,
all of the icons,
all the colors,
everything like that.
The big question,
especially for me and Damon,
is when you're faced with
a Photoshop mockup like that,
how do you go about
converting that
into actual running code?
And our first one is you have
to be involved in the design.
Because you don't want
to end up with something
that you're not able
to implement.
The converse and that...
I really also ought to emphasize
is we've certainly been
strongly asked
to implement stuff
that we thought
wasn't possible
that we were actually
able to do.
The designers are acting
as advocates
for a great user experience,
so it's very important,
if they consider something
to be important or vital,
that we make our best
possible effort to do it
and don't just say,
well, you know,
rounded corners are a pain.
Let's just make it
all square boxes.
[chuckling]
Rounded corners are a pain.
So the other point--
you need to know
CSS and the HTML DOM.
You need to know
what your toolkit is,
and unfortunately
at the moment,
there's no way of
getting around the fact
that because you're building
for a browser
you have to understand HTML
and you have to understand CSS.
Because fundamentally,
it comes down to
what is the appropriate
DOM structure
that you're going to build
with your code
and how am I
going to use G-W-T
to create that structure
and manipulate it?
While G-W-T is going to remove
your browser specific JavaScript
and DOM issues,
you still have to deal with
cross browser CSS issues,
and you still have to
deal with browser quirks
with things like
the Peekaboo bug
and various other stuff
that Damon could name
off the top of his head
that just cause you
enormous pain
when you get it working first
in Firefox,
and it doesn't work in IE6.
As an example,
I'm gonna go through
how we construct basically
something that looks very much
like this panel
here at the bottom.
And this is the actual example
that you can download
in its final state.
We've got a little add button
that you click,
so we're adding these rows
with a bit of animation.
We have a nice rounded ended
highlight thing.
And again, you know,
you click the X,
and it's removed
with a bit of animation.
So I quite like it.
I think that looks okay.
Go ahead and build that.
I'm gonna start
with the header now.
As I get into this,
you will see that what
I am talking about doing
is not what was described
as the fastest way to do it
in the previous talk
that I just watched.
So I'm gonna talk about nesting
a bunch of GWT widgets
to get my layout
to look right.
If I was gonna do it fast,
I should probably use an
HTML panel with a lot of divs,
but I don't...we...
because we're not building
a toolkit,
we spend our time optimizing
the bits that are gonna be slow.
And a lot of the time
if it's fast enough,
it's good enough for us.
We will also do things like,
you know,
we're gonna build the special,
the specific case
that we're interested in
because we don't have to build
a generalized layout system
or a generalized system for
supporting any sort of header.
So in this case here,
what's the easiest way
to do this?
I'm gonna have
an outer-like div
surrounding all my contents.
I'm gonna use a FlowPanel
for that.
That's nice.
I can use two FlowPanels
inside that,
and I can use CSS
to make sure that I get
the right-hand side
to float to the right
and the left-hand side
to float to the left.
I can use a GWT button
for the add button.
And then I can use two labels
to get me the top
and the bottom.
And when I put them
inside the FlowPanel,
they're gonna stack
vertically nicely.
And I'm actually gonna get
the behavior I want.
I'm gonna get
the resize behavior I want
without any effort.
So all I do is I go ahead.
I create my two labels.
I'm building
from the inside out.
I create my two labels,
create the left-hand side,
set the style
and the two labels,
create the button,
create the right-hand side,
create the final header,
and put both of them in there.
I don't bother creating
a special, you know,
comp me--header widget
that extends Composite
and wrap all this together,
because I'm just doing
the specific header
that I want right now.
And again, this...
is gonna be slower
than doing it with HTML Panel
and divs,
but on the other hand,
you probably wouldn't
be able to tell in our app.
The next one is
we're moving out.
We've got this outer panel here,
which is this thing
with rounded corners.
And there are lots of different
ways of doing rounded corners,
and we have probably tried
every single one of them...
from, you know, Sliding Doors
to single-width,
single-height divs
to something that Damon invented
that has things
absolutely positioned
in the left and right.
The easiest way to do this one
is a 9-cell table, of course.
So I can stick the content
in the center
and I can use...
background images
to get the look that I want.
And the great thing
about this
is G-W-T provides you
a decorator panel
that makes it dead easy.
And here's a case where
I'm going to go ahead
and actually create a...
a widget of my own
to do it.
I'm using Composite
because I don't want to expose
any methods that I'm not
actually going to use,
particularly because
I'm building
a very specific case here
where I pass the header
and the content in
when I construct it.
So I don't want to have
to support a use case
where someone says,
"I want to remove the content
and add something else
later on."
And then here's
the two bits of CSS
that are gonna give me the top
left and the top center images.
The point about this
is really
those two classes,
top left and top center,
are set on the DOM structure
created by
the GWT decorator panel.
So how do you know...
what classes
are actually available for you
in the styling?
You can look
at the documentation,
but what we tend to do
is knock up a quick example
and then use Firebug
or the IE Developer Toolkit
and go in and see,
you know,
what's the actual structure
of what you've got.
This is another one
which is in...
contradiction of what
we have been told previously.
Handling Window Resizing.
So how do we handle
window resizing?
What you want to do,
of course,
is you want to use HTML
and CSS.
You want to build it
so that the browser handles
the resizing automatically.
The problem is,
the content in the center cell
of that example
does not work like that.
At least, I couldn't get it
to work like that
across all the browsers.
So with static HTML...
I'm doomed.
With GWT, I can do
programmatic layout.
And we do programmatic layout.
If you look at Blueprint,
we do quite a bit
of programmatic layout
in various places, when
panels are removed or added.
And from seeing the GWT 2.0 talk
this morning,
we are looking forward
to panels that do all that
automatically for us.
At the moment, what we do
is we listen to the ResizeEvent
from the window,
calculate the child-size
and propagate it down.
What we haven't done, though,
is build something
like GridBagLayout
for anyone
who's worked on Swing.
We haven't built GridBagLayout,
we haven't built a general
layout manager that takes...
anything, you know,
configurable sizes
and stuff like that.
We program specifically
for what is the layout behavior
of this particular thing
that we want.
And there is actually
one extra wrinkle.
Decorator panel doesn't support
having a widget in the header
as it's currently built.
And if you read that blog post,
you can see the very small
change I had to do
to actually support that.
I move on to
the List and the Row.
This is very similar
to the header,
so I use a FlowPanel
to create the list,
and I vertically stack a bunch
of divs to form the rows.
And each of those rows is
made up of a number of sections
which float to the left
and the right appropriately.
Now, of course, when you're
floating the stuff
to the right,
to the right in IE6,
you have to add it
in the opposite order,
or else it doesn't float
correctly...
which you only discover
when you get to IE6
after you've written it
on Firefox.
The more interesting,
potentially, point of that
is, you know, rounded corners.
Rounded corners highlight
is quite nice
and the designer said,
"We really want the rounded
corner highlight."
And in this case,
because we're prepared to accept
a fixed-height row,
I don't have to go
for a fancy...you know,
multicell table solution
that will handle rows
of different heights.
I just say we're gonna have
a 46-pixel or whatever it is
high row.
And that lets me just use
background images,
and CSS Style
did the whole thing.
So I create a MouseHandler
for the mouseover event.
And because I can get hold
of the source of the event,
I can get hold of the row
and just call a mouseover
method on that
and add a focused style to it.
The mouseout
does the opposite thing--
takes away the focused style.
And it's simply a case
of saying
inside my row
on my rightEndCap...
it's normally white
when the row
also has the focused style.
I'm gonna give it
a background-image,
and that works very nicely.
The final thing I want
to talk about is animation.
For animation,
you've gotta use JavaScript,
and therefore,
you've gotta use GWT.
Certainly for the browsers
we support,
there's no CSS3 support
right now.
I mean, the majority
of our customers use IE6.
So though it was nice to see
all those HTML5 features
this morning,
until someone can find a way
to automatically update
all those IE6 browsers
to something else,
we are still writing to a really
low lowest common denominator.
A little animation
goes a long way.
Don't overdo it.
We've overdone it
in some cases
and then had to
take it out again.
But it really does help
users understand the behavior.
So, you know, if you click
the delete button
and then the row
suddenly disappears
and then the row above
moves into its space
and it doesn't look--
especially if you scroll
off the bottom of the screen,
like anything
has actually happened
apart from the name
has changed--
a bit of animation
can help you understand
what's actually going on.
And generally,
you're gonna change
the size, the position,
or the opacity of elements.
And to do the fading
in and out,
I'm gonna use
the GWT Animation class
and create a subclass of that.
And I'm gonna override
the onUpdate method,
because that's the only thing
I actually need.
This is basically where
I'm gonna have my row class.
Previously,
I create FadingRow
which is gonna use
my new FadeInAnimation
which is a subclass
of animation.
So when I add the row,
I just add it as normal
to my listPanel,
to my FlowPanel,
then I call the fadeIn method.
FadeIn creates me
new animation
which I tell to execute,
and it's gonna run
for 3/4 of a second.
And my FadeInAnimation
is gonna extend Animation,
and all it does
is set the opacity.
Now, this DOMHelper class
is an example
of deferred binding
because, of course,
setting Opacity,
the way you do that varies
across browsers.
Particularly IE6.
You've got to use filters.
So this DOMHelper
has multiple implementations
that are chosen at compile time
in order to get
the right effect.
So that was really the...
the UI portion of it,
really an infinite amount
of taking pains
and really concentrating hard
on trying to get
a great user experience.
Damon's gonna
talk more about
how to get it
to work quickly.
Lundin: Okay, I'm gonna
shift gears a little bit
and talk about some of
the performance challenges
that we've had
and how you go about building
a highly performing
and complex application.
Before I begin,
I want to show one of the most
performance intensive parts
of our product.
Here's the process
that Alex has been working on.
He's been showing you
what we call our map view
which is a very simplified view
of a business process
that a user may be creating.
In addition to this,
we have another view
on the same data
that we call
our process diagram.
So we switch over here,
and this allows us to build--
this allows the user
to build out
more detail into their process
than they could before.
So let's say
we submitted a talk.
We can insert a decision here.
And we can say, you know,
was the talk accepted?
Oops.
[chuckles]
Yes, thank you.
If no, then perhaps,
you know, we reevaluate.
And then we go back and maybe
want to try again next year.
We can also insert Swimlanes
which represent
a person that's performing
a particular action,
so let's add one
for Alex and myself.
And then we can simply
assign tasks
by dragging these items
into different Swimlanes.
I'm just gonna make
a bit of a mess here
to show you some of the more
interesting things
that we can do.
We can add sub-processes,
expandable and collapsible
sub-processes
so the users can decide
what level of detail
they wanna see in their
particular process.
Now, for those of you who are
thinking to yourself
that we've reinvented Visio
on the Web,
I wanna point out
that there's a very
important distinction here
and that is as you saw me
editing this process here,
I didn't have to worry about
where I was putting these items
and how I was drawing
the lines.
Blueprint basically
did all that work for me.
Blueprint has built into it
a very sophisticated
positioning
and routing algorithm.
And this helps the user
resist the temptation
to spend hours fiddling
with where, exactly,
all their boxes go
and how to get all those
little kinks out of their lines.
But because of that,
it means that
we have this computationally
intensive algorithm
that sucks up
a lot of CPU cycles.
And so that makes it
very difficult for us
to spend a lot of time
doing other things.
Unfortunately for us,
we also have another
significant constraint,
and that is most of
our customers
are corporate business users
who have little or no control
over their own machines.
They can't install software,
they can't install plugins.
We're basically limited
to what those users have.
And despite all of the tears
of frustration that we have,
most of them
are still using IE6.
And unfortunately,
because of that,
it means we have to write
an application
that will work
even under IE6.
And IE6 is, in fact,
what we're using here
for this demo.
Let me insert a link
to a larger process...
Aptly called Large Process.
And let's open this up.
So I'm gonna open up a larger,
more complex process
to show you a better idea
of scale
on the types of things
that we can do
in this application.
Every time the user
reviews a process
or every time
we make a change--
when I added a new item
or I drew a new line
or I expanded or collapsed
a sub-process,
this algorithmic in Blueprint
is generating the entire layout
every time.
And that's something that
we need to do pretty quickly.
So let's zoom out here and take
a look at what we've got here.
So this is something that
Blueprint generated
the entire layout for this
when I open
this particular process.
So let's talk about
how exactly we did this.
Well, the implementation
that you see here
is not the first implementation
of this that we did.
The original implementation
we did is done in a pattern
that's probably very familiar
to a lot of you
and which I have
some example code up here.
It's pretty traditional.
This is traditional GWT code,
something you might see
in Swing or Eclipse
or any other UI-based framework,
and it looks like this.
In our case, we're gonna
iterate over all of these items
that we wanna display
on our diagram,
and we're gonna create
a widget
to represent
each one of those items.
Now, these widgets
are not simple objects.
They're complex objects.
They have other widgets,
FlowPanels, text areas, images,
and other things like that
nested inside of them.
In addition,
we're gonna want to create
keyboard and mouse handlers,
'cause we wanna be able
to respond to user action,
so we create handlers and we
attach those to our widgets.
And then once we've got
our widget,
we add it to a root panel
and it becomes
part of our application.
Well, unfortunately,
this breaks down at some level.
One of the most
expensive things
that you can do in JavaScript
is object creation
and garbage collection,
particularly in IE6.
Now, this is something that
has gotten much better
with every version of
the new browsers that come out.
But if you're still having
to program against IE6,
this is gonna be one of
your biggest problems.
Every time I create
one of those widgets
as well as all of those
nested widgets inside,
every image, every text box,
each time you do that,
GWT is constructing
a JavaScript objects.
So if you have
a lot of widgets,
especially a lot of
complex widgets,
you're creating
a lot of object.
It could be hundreds,
thousands,
or even tens of thousands
of objects.
If you're doing that,
you're gonna find
that your application
behaves very slow.
In addition, we're creating
a JavaScript object
for every one of those handlers.
That's, again, a whole bunch
of JavaScript objects
that we're creating.
Once we create those,
we're having to attach them
to every one of those widgets.
Now, before any of you
think I'm dissing G-W-T here,
I want to point out that
this pattern that I've just
been talking about
is what we use for almost
our entire application.
The things
that Alex just showed,
the map that he did a demo of,
uses that pattern.
It works most of the time.
But it breaks down
when the scale increases.
It doesn't scale...
as it did in the case
of our diagram.
Especially where we have
all these computationally
expensive algorithm.
We can't spend a lot of time
creating JavaScript objects.
So...how do we deal with that?
Well, when we looked at coming
up with another implementation,
the most important thing to us
was to make sure that we
improved the responsiveness
of the application.
We wanted to make sure that
when the user opens a process
or they make a change
to one of their processes
and we have to generate
a new layout for it,
we want to get that result
to the user
and show it to them
as quickly as possible.
Well, the fastest way
to do that
is to, unfortunately,
regress to an earlier style
of programming
and revert to generating
raw HTML
instead of creating
all those widgets.
In addition,
instead of creating handlers
and attaching handlers
to all of our widgets,
we're gonna use
fly-weight handlers.
We'll have one instance
for every type of item
instead of every widget.
In our case, we have
12 different types of item.
That's a fixed number.
In our case, we'll have 24,
so one for rendering
and one for event handling.
And then instead of
attaching handlers
to every one
of our widgets,
we're gonna attach a handler
at one location on the diagram.
Let's go through these
in a little more detail.
So here we have
how we do our rendering.
So this may look
familiar to you.
This probably looks like
servlet code.
But I want to remind you,
this is not servlet code.
This is code running in GWT
in JavaScript on the client.
We start off by creating
a string buffer,
and then just as we did before,
we're gonna iterate over
all of the items
that we want to display
in our diagram,
and we're gonna request
one of these fly-weight
renderers that we have
to generate the HTML
for that particular item.
And you can see that
down here at the bottom.
We simply append a bunch
of HTML to our string buffer.
We add the dynamic elements
to it such as the id,
its position...
any other of that information
that belongs to
that layout.
Once we have the HTML
for our entire diagram,
we simply call this
setInnerHTML
and it inserts all of that
HTML into the DOM all at once.
This is the fastest way
to generate
dynamic content on the client.
When I was preparing
for this talk,
I went back and I looked
through some of the prototyping
that we did for this,
and some of the numbers
we saw,
you could get up to 12 times
improvement by doing this
versus having
very complex widgets.
Now let's talk about
Event Handling.
So here we've got
some example HTML.
This is sort of a snippet
of the HTML
that we might have produced
from this rendering
that we just had.
In this case,
we've got two items
represented by those two divs
up there at the top.
Let's see what happens
when a user clicks on
one of these elements.
What happens is
the user generates an event
at that innermost element
that the user clicked on.
In this case,
that innermost DIV.
The browser's gonna take
that element, that event,
and bubble it up through
the HTML hierarchy
until it gets to the top.
And this is where
we're gonna put
that single listener
I mentioned before...
which looks like this.
So here we have
this diagram class,
and the first thing
we're doing
is we're calling this
sinkEvents method.
What this does is it
enables this class
to listen for events
on this particular element.
Now before,
we were creating handlers
for every one of our widgets,
and we were attaching
those handlers
to every one
of those widgets.
Now, with a single call,
with one line of code,
I've enabled handling
for our entire diagram.
Every time an event occurs
anywhere within your diagram,
this method on browser event
gets called.
Fortunately,
the browser tells us
what, exactly, it was
that the user clicked on
from this getEventTarget
method.
That's gonna be
that innermost DIV
that I mentioned before.
Now, we don't really wanna know
what the innermost element was.
We wanna know what that DIV
sort of at the top was,
the DIV that represents
that top of that item.
So what we do is we simply
walk backwards up the hierarchy
until we find an element
that has an ID attribute on it.
Once we've found that,
we know we've gotten to the top
and now we know what item
it was that the user clicked on
and we know its ID.
Once we know the item
that the user clicked on,
we can look up its type
and then we can forward
this call
to a handler
for that specific type.
And then we can allow
a handler to handle that event,
that item in a way
that's specific to that
particular type of item,
whatever it was.
Now, this works in simple cases
such as mouseover.
Let's say you want to
highlight a bunch of items
as you're moving the mouse
across the screen.
Well, when you're doing that,
all you need to know
is what element it was
that the user
moved their mouse over.
But let's say like
instead of mouseover
the user has clicked
on an item,
and they're now dragging it
across the screen.
Well, we want to know
not just what element it was
that the user is dragging,
but we wanna know
what other elements
are underneath of it
or what elements may be near it,
because we wanna find
possible drop targets.
Well, at this point,
all we have is a bunch of
HTML that we've generated.
Really what we need
is we need some more
useful data structures.
We want to be able to
organize some data structures
into, perhaps,
bounding boxes
or something else
that's interesting
so I don't have to search
the entire diagram.
We really want get back
some of what we lost
when we had
those widgets before.
Previously, we could
ask the widgets, you know,
are you a possible
drop target?
And they can answer that.
And unfortunately,
we don't have those anymore.
One thing I want to go back to
is that number one goal
that we had before
which was we wanted
to make sure
that when the user
makes a change,
we want to show
that response to them
as quickly as possible.
Setting up these interesting
data structures
is not necessary
to doing that.
So we want to make sure
that when we generate this HTML
that we get that
to the user immediately,
and only after that
do we wanna spend any time
that we need
to set up these data structures.
And this is how that works.
So we start off here.
We've got all of the HTML
that we've generated
from our layout code.
We've inserted into the DOM.
The next thing we do
is we execute a DeferredCommand.
And what this does
is it gives the browser
the opportunity
to actually render that HTML
and show it to the user.
When the browser
is finished doing that,
it will call
this DeferredCommand
and execute
this createCache function.
That cache function will
basically iterate over the DOM.
All the information
that we need,
where things are positioned,
and how, exactly,
things are laid out
is encoded
right there in the DOM.
So all we're gonna do
is we're gonna parse
the information back out.
So here we get the element
from one of our items,
we parse out its id,
its position,
and then we can do
whatever we want
with that data structure.
We can arrange them
in any interesting way
so that we can do
event handling in the future.
Okay, now let's say
that you've done
all of these things.
You're down to raw HTML,
you're down to single listeners,
and you're finding that
things still are a little slow.
Maybe you've got an application
where under certain conditions
things get too complicated
and your application really
can't execute quickly enough.
Well, there's one thing
that is unique to G-W-T,
and that is you can
compile your code
into both Java bytecode
and into JavaScript.
Then your application
can decide at runtime
whether or not to execute
that piece of code
on the client
or on the server.
You're gonna find
that in many cases
the Java VM is much faster
than the JavaScript engines,
particularly those in IE6.
Now, again, those keep getting
better in every generation
but if you're still working
with an older browser,
you're gonna find that
the Java VM really is
much faster.
So now we get
to the point where
we wanna decide...do I execute
this particular piece of code
on the client, or do I
execute it on the server?
Well, we argued over
a number of different options,
you know, try and predict
how fast each one's gonna take,
try and measure or estimate
network bandwidth or latency.
But we decided in the end
that the simplest algorithm
was the best.
And the way that works is
every time the user opens
a process for the first time--
we're gonna go ahead
and we're just
gonna do that on the client.
Now, that could potentially
be slow,
but we're only gonna
do that the first time.
If that's not slow,
if the user's using
a modern browser that's quick
or they're working on
a small process,
then we can continue
to generate those layout
on the client.
That'll give them the most
consistent and most responsive
interaction
with our application.
But if it turns out
it's not fast,
if it's under
a certain threshold,
in our case, two seconds,
what's gonna happen
is the next time we do a layout
we're gonna execute it
on the server instead.
When we do that,
we're gonna measure
the entire round trip.
We're gonna send a request
to the server
and measure how long it takes
to send that
and get a response back.
Once we've done that,
we know how fast the server is
and we know how fast
the client is,
and from there on out,
we can simply pick whichever
the two of those is fastest.
We also keep a running average,
so if for some reason,
one of those starts to get slow
over the other,
we can actually just dynamically
switch back and forth.
For us, the way that we do it
is we use a GWT RPC call.
The interface
is actually very simple.
We make an RPC call.
We simply ask the server
generate a layout
for this particular process,
and it pretty much
just sends us a string
with a bunch of HTML back in it.
Now, because of that great
cache function
I showed you a minute ago,
the client
already has the ability
to parse the information,
the layout information it needs,
right out of that HTML.
So I actually wanted
to give a quick demo
to show how exactly
this works.
So I'm gonna add a little
debug parameter...
up here on our URL
to show us what's happening.
Now, when I changed the URL,
it's basically causing
this process to reload,
so this is as if the user
is coming into this process
for the first time.
And as I said before,
we're gonna generate
a client side layout.
I don't know
if you can all see that,
but that says client layout
4,047 milliseconds.
That's obviously longer than
that 2-second threshold we had.
So if I make a change
to this process,
the next layout should
occur on the server.
Server layout--797 milliseconds.
So this is about
five times faster.
So I hit undo...
688 milliseconds.
So as you can see,
in one case,
the client is slow,
but then we figure that out
and we start executing the next
operations on the server.
Now, there's one interesting
point about this
which is this demonstration
right here
actually gets less impressive
every year,
and that's because the client
actually is getting faster.
And I think this is a good
testament to using G-W-T
and a good argument
for why you should use it.
Every time a new version
of G-W-T is released,
our application gets faster.
We originally did this test
on 1.3
when we upgraded from--
excuse me, on 1.4.
When we upgraded to 1.5.,
we saw about a 10% improvement
sort of in general
across our entire application.
And that's part of
the reason why
I've done this demo before
and instead of 5X,
we've seen 9X difference
between the client
and the server.
So as the client gets faster,
this becomes less important.
I've done a couple of tests
with 1.6
which we haven't upgraded to
in production yet.
We haven't seen a general
performance improvement
for that,
but for three of the processes
where I did a test
for our layout portion
of it,
two of them were 33% faster,
and one of them
was 150% faster.
And we didn't have to do
anything.
All we had to do
was upgrade the version
of G-W-T that we're using.
And then finally,
to wrap up,
we have just
a couple of slides
that are just sort of a bunch
of random tidbits that we have,
random thoughts
that we thought were useful.
I don't know those of you
who were at Bruce's talk
this morning,
but he mentioned the fact
that compiling G-W-T code
is very slow.
For those of you
that started with 1.4 earlier,
you know that when 1.5.
came out,
it got a lot slower.
Now, it's worth it,
given all the optimizations
that the compiler does,
but sometimes
it can be very painful.
By default, when you ask
G-W-T to compile your Java
into JavaScript,
it's going to do that
for five different browsers.
Now, when you are actively
working on development,
you don't usually
need to be doing that.
Usually, you're actively
debugging
and working only on
a single browser at a time.
Well, a very useful trick
is that you can actually
tell G-W-T
to only compile
for a single browser
or a single locale
or a single permutation.
So this is one of our
G-W-T module XML files.
We simply have a line in here
that we keep commented out,
and when I'm doing debugging
and I wanna only build for,
in this case, Internet Explorer,
I simply uncomment that line,
and next time I do a compile
it's only gonna generate
the JavaScript
for Internet Explorer.
You're gonna find that this
saves you a lot of time.
Moffat: Hosted mode
is another choice.
Lundin: Yes.
Yes, if you're using
hosted mode--
Moffat: 'Cause I'm on the Mac,
so I can't use hosted mode
to do IE6,
which is why I want GBT 2.0.
Lundin: Yes. Yeah, the main
advantage of hosted mode
is, obviously, you don't
have to compile at all.
You simply launch hosted mode,
and it compiles on the fly.
You make a change,
you simply hit refresh,
and it happens very quickly.
This will probably actually
become completely unnecessary
when G-W-T 2.0 comes out
and they release the out of
process hosted mode,
in which case you're almost
never going to need to
actually compile--
do a GWT compile.
A similar...
tip that you can use
for this
is that if you have
an application
that's particularly large,
you can also consider splitting
it into multiple modules.
So in the case of Blueprint,
we have a home page module,
we have a process page module,
admin page module.
When I'm doing development,
I'm likely only working
on one of those at a time.
So if I make changes
to a particular piece of code,
I only recompile
that particular module.
And it saves
a little bit of time
instead of having to recompile
the entire application.
Moffat: And also, sorry,
in 1.6 we...
so at the moment for 1.53
we do our builds in Ant,
and we use
the Ant parallel task.
So we actually run like
all of our seven page--
all of our compiles at once
at the same time.
And then I've experimented a bit
with local workers in 1.64,
you know, 'cause you can turn
the number of local workers
up and down,
and how does that interact
with parallel compiles?
And for a single page,
it's faster for us
to run like as many
local workers as you have cause.
But if you're doing
multiple pages,
it's still faster first
to run, you know,
multiple pages in parallel.
Because the portion
at the front of the compiler
where it works out
what the permutations are...
is for our page
is a fair portion
of the actual compile time.
So we don't save too much
if you're in a whole bunch
of many local worker threads
in parallel.
Lundin: And just
a few more comments.
If you find yourself doing
a lot of DOM operations
that are related to style,
if you find yourself
basically
imbedding CSS constants
in your application
and calling getStyle
at setProperty
with a value that never changes,
don't do that.
Instead of executing
that code in GWT,
which is a JavaScript
operation,
put that in a CSS file.
Your browser can evaluate
the CSS much faster
than it can execute
the JavaScript
and perform
that DOM manipulation.
Avoid using iterators
over a list.
This is a very minor point,
but it's a very simple
thing to avoid doing.
Every time you create
an iterator,
which, unfortunately,
is also with
the for each
language construct,
that creates
a JavaScript object.
And as I've already said,
JavaScript object creation
is relatively expensive.
If you iterate over the list
using an index instead,
you saved yourself the creation
of a JavaScript object.
If you find that you have
a long list
of things
that you were creating
that may be taking you
a long time,
one thing that you can do
to improve the perceived
performance of your application
is split it into
incremental commands.
Just like that deferred command
that I mentioned before,
IncrementalCommand will allow
you to show your application
in chunks.
So if you have
a large list of things,
you can show the first block
of things to the user
while you're sort of
in the background
working on
the next set of it.
Now, it will still take
the same amount of time
to do the entire thing,
but at least you can get
the results,
the first bits of results
to the user right away
instead of making them wait
for the entire thing.
And then lastly, when we've
done performance testing,
you can't use hosted mode
for performance testing
because
of the various com calls
or the various integrations
with a browser.
It doesn't behave
like a real browser would.
In hosted mode you have
gtw-Log and System.out
you can take advantage of.
But you don't have those things
in an actual browser.
And so there are a number
of things that you can do
to try and get information
out of your browser,
and one of the simplest
things that we do
is simply open your application
in another frame
and call document.write
on that frame,
and you basically get
a console on your application.
There's also a couple of
toolkits that you can do
that do things similar.
There's gwt-log library
as well as the Logging library
in the gwt incubator.
Moffat: We've also
done stuff with...
there's a...
package of code
called episodes,
and the guy that wrote Yslow
that collects performance
data on the client
and then uses a web beacon
to transfer it across
to the server.
And then you can pull it out
of the web request logs.
So we've actually got that in,
so on the production site,
we can track how long
it takes for people
to go from on unload
on page A
to load
to the beginning of page B
so we know what server time is
in the round-trip time.
And then we track various
other significant points
until the end of either
on module load
or to the pages loaded.
And those are very
interesting numbers
because you can see,
you know,
what sort of performance
are people actually
seeing on their browsers.
So it's well worth
implementing that sort of stuff
and also stuff--
we also have code in there
where, if we get an exception
on the client,
we send the information
back across to the server
and dump it into
our debug logs,
even if we're not
gonna show it to the customer.
Which is a similar thing
to what was mentioned
in the previous talk
about using a search
instead of throwing exceptions.
It's useful, if you've got
that sort of an error, though,
to send it across
to the server,
because you're clearly
having a problem in production
and you'd like to know about it
rather than have people see,
you know, exceptions
or little pop-ups
at the bottom of their browsers.
Lundin: Yep. And then I had
one last point on this
that I guess didn't make it
up on the slide which is
if you're working on GWT
and you've got RPC calls
that you've been making,
you may find the temptation
to send an empty HTML page
or near-empty HTML page
to the client
when the user first logs
into your application
and then make a subsequent
RPC call
to actually fetch
all the data.
What you can do instead
is you can actually imbed
the data that you need
right in the page.
So in the example
of our processes,
there's an awful lot
of information
that we want to show
to the user right away.
And the way that we do that
is we embed that data
directly in the web page.
You can either use JSON
for that
or with, as with GWT 1.5,
you can actually fake
an RPC call on the server
and take its payload and embed
it directly in the HTML.
Moffat: "Faking"--
he's making it sound like
it's not supported,
but it actually is supported.
It's a perfectly reasonable
legitimate way
to go about doing this.
Lundin: It doesn't actually
make an RPC call,
but it generates
the same data--
Moffat: You serialize
the payload
as if for an RPC call,
stuff it into the HTML,
and then pass it on
the client.
Lundin: Yep. So that's all
we have for our presentation.
If you have any questions,
please come up to the mike.
[applause]
Moffat: Thank you.
And no one has any questions.
Excellent.
[Lundin laughs]
man: Thank you for...
Moffat: Yes?
man: Thank you for
a good presentation.
A quick question.
You mentioned several times
about how expensive it is
to create a JavaScript object.
Is there any work being done
that would make it
a lot less expensive
to create a JavaScript object?
And is there also any work
that you may be aware of
where we can actually,
instead of interpreting
JavaScript code,
you can actually
compel JavaScript code
and have it run--
Lundin: I'm sorry,
what was that last bit?
Moffat: Compile it, I mean--
man: Compel it. Right.
So it's already
in machine-language format
so you can run it
immediately.
Moffat: I mean--
man: Having it built
on the server
and just ship it to the client
in machine-language format.
Moffat: I mean, it's out of our
area of expertise,
to be honest.
We're sort of stuck with
the browsers that we're stuck
with supporting,
which get better and better.
I know that the...
like Squirrelfish,
whatever
that's now called in V8,
do...
compilation-to-machine code
on the client.
I mean, they do the same
sort of things that JVMs do.
And...you know,
there was a thing
that Microsoft put out
about, you know,
what's the best thing that--
what do you want us to do
most in our IE9?
And the one thing we want most
is to get rid of IE6,
that they can't do.
I mean, that's just--
unfortunately, we're at about...
like 60 or 70% of our users
are on that thing.
I mean,
once that goes away,
life is gonna get so much
easier--we hope, of course.
Lundin: Yeah, the basic
answer to your question
is yes, there is work
being done on that,
but it's being done
by the browser venders.
And so as long as you're stuck
supporting older browsers...
Moffat: As it's politely
phrased--older browsers,
less capable browsers.
Lundin: GWT has been doing
its best to make that faster,
and it's doing
a pretty good job of it.
man: Uh, the question is
have you compared
the performance of your
Internet Explorer 6 application
compared to Chrome
and Mozilla?
Because your recommendation's
how true they are
compared to different browsers.
Lundin: It's kinda interesting
because we know that
they're faster,
and even considerably faster,
so we actually
don't pay attention
to their performance
very much,
because we know
if it works for IE6
then we're gonna be good
on all the other browsers.
Moffat: There are some posts
on our blog
where I have done comparisons.
I mean, I've done
7, 8 Safari...
Firefox and Chrome.
I didn't do 6 because
it was just so appalling.
I mean, even between those,
there's quite a difference.
I mean, things are getting
really very, very fast now.
Some of those demos
that we saw during the keynote
this morning
where they were doing stuff
in JavaScript...
it's pretty amazing.
And with the compilation
improvements as well,
things are executing
a lot faster now
than even when we started
a couple of years ago.
man: Getting away from the
performance topic for a second,
what kind of
back button behavior
does your application have?
And does GWT give you
a reasonable way
to handle the back button
to make it be
whatever you want it to be?
Moffat: Pardon?
man: The back button.
Moffat: Oh, the back button!
Yes, GWT gives us
complete history support.
So it's fine.
You can do stuff like--
I mean, not just back
between pages--
but certainly in the...
the process map, isn't it?
On the process page...
if you're on a diagram
and you hit the back button,
you can go back to the map page.
So it's more a case of actually
implementing it than...
You basically follow
what they've documented
as the way that you should do
it, and it works.
There's no special tricks
or anything.
They provide like
a history frame
that you have to include
in your HTML.
And then they use--I can't
remember exactly how it's done.
I think it's done using hashtags
in the URL of the history frame.
man: Right. Some of my users
think of the back button
as the undo button.
I wonder if you ran into that
in your UI testing.
Moffat: Ah, no.
We actually have an undo button.
Which is labeled undo,
so hopefully we can get
away from that one.
man: Hi. I have a question
about the first part
of the presentation.
Moffat: Yes?
man: The UI stuff?
When you were showing
adding the users
and the little highlight thing,
you mentioned that
it's sort of an easy case
because it's always gonna be
46 pixels high.
And I'm wondering if you've
ever taken into account...
when sometimes users
will change
the size of the text
in their browser
and how you factor that into
your design.
Moffat: We're--we're--
I mean, let's be honest.
We're very bad.
I mean, we don't.
We just--it's gonna be like--
it's gonna look like this
if you stick with
these font sizes.
If you change the font size,
it's gonna look bad.
I mean...
I mean, that's one of the ones
where we're...the...
I don't know how
to phrase it properly.
Sometimes just good enough
is good enough for us.
We try and get it
to look really good,
the way we want it
to be displayed,
but people doing
that sort of thing to--
Also the other one
that's a big pain
is changing DPI settings...
can really play havoc
with the diagram.
man: Yeah, 'cause in the
application that I'm working on,
we're trying to deal with,
you know,
users with different
screen sizes.
Moffat: Yes.
man: And a lot of times,
when a user has a big screen,
the first thing they'll do
is just jack up the font size.
Moffat: Yeah, yeah, I mean...
it can be done,
but it's a lot more--
it's obviously a lot more work
because you can't just say
I'm gonna have
a fixed-height element.
The other thing to do
is to push back on the...
because it's a tradeoff,
isn't it?
If you didn't have to have
the rounded ends
on that highlight...
you could actually do it
pretty easily,
and it would look
fairly nice.
man: Like using EM?
Moffat: Yeah.
Or you can--the other one
I'd really like us to try
at some point is some sort
of progressive enhancement.
So, you know, if you're on
like a more capable browser,
you get the better look,
but we can support a basic look
that works with different
front sizes
on less capable browsers.
On all browsers, you can change
the font size and it looks okay.
If you're using a more modern
one, you get rounded corners.
But it's a case of...
sometimes product management
isn't prepared to accept
the slightly less ugly look
in exchange for a benefit
that, really, they don't see
anyone is prepared to pay for,
honestly.
man: Thanks.
man: We spend a lot of effort
trying to be happy
with automated unit tests,
and GWT test case
is relatively slow,
so what we found is--
and I'm hoping you have better
approaches than what we found--
is taking our controllers
and having--
controllers
have no GWT code in them
but just receive events,
they tally all events.
Then we can test that
the event handling is correct,
and then assume
that the UI will react
according to the events,
but the logic, at least,
the business logic
with event handling
could be separated
into a standard JDA test
What else is there?
What have you done to be able
to really, really--
or hopefully really
unit test this also quickly?
Moffat: You're like preaching
to the choir here.
This is exactly
what Damon is all about
is exactly the thing
that you're talking about.
Because that thing is so slow,
taking the UI
out of the equation
is really all we've
been able to do...
and, like you say,
rely on the fact
that if someone
presses a button,
the button event
is going to get to us.
So what we have to test
is from the controller
through the model
and make sure that the model
is transformed in the right way.
I haven't really seen
anything else.
And we still have problems,
of course, with...
we'd like an automated way
to be able to script
actual browser testing
so that we can automatically
run IE6 and Firefox and IE7,
all those sorts of tests
through the actual browser.
And, again, it's still
a painful process.
Lundin: There is one thing
that we found that--
man:...using selenium
to do that?
Moffat: Pardon?
man: Are you using selenium
to run--
Moffat: No. We're using...
wattage--no, not wattage.
We're using Watir.
The Ruby-based one.
Lundin: One point
I was gonna add
is if you have a lot of
interaction with native
JavaScript objects,
then your hosted mode test
will be much slower.
For a long time, like I said,
our application,
which was originally
written in JavaScript,
and so we had a core
heart of our application
that remained JavaScript
for a very long time.
And when we finally
got rid of it
and made it 100% GWT,
one set of tests dropped
from 12 minutes to 2 minutes.
By getting rid of
the native interaction.
man: Maybe you just
answered my question.
Can you tell me about
your experiences
going from Dojo to G-W-T?
Moffat: Um...right,
so I mean, originally...
originally what we did
was we built the original thing
using Flash and HTML
with our own JavaScript.
And that really
was pretty terrible,
because the interaction
with Flash and HTML
drag and drop's awful.
Then we moved over to Dojo,
and we managed to build
a first version with Dojo.
The problem was, it was pretty
much un-maintainable.
We found it very,
very difficult
to deal with large quantities
of JavaScript.
When we moved over to GWT,
or G-W-T,
we...rewrote pretty much
page-by-page,
and it came down to
it was faster to rewrite...
the UI as GWT code
and keep sort of
the client side model
as JavaScript for a while.
So what we would have would be
all the data would be stored
effectively in JSON
in JavaScript
in the client,
and then we'd have
a GWT front end on top of that
and JSNI methods calling
back and forth between the two.
What we did end up with
after that, though,
was a bunch of G-W-T code
that looked like
converted Dojo code.
So it was sort of
fairly horrible,
and we've gradually
been going through
getting rid of that.
The app was much smaller
at the time
we did the conversion.
And there weren't really any...
there were no "gotchas"
that I think we ran into.
It was just a case of going
ahead and doing it,
and it turned out to be--
to really be pretty easy.
I mean, obviously, we wouldn't
be up here otherwise.
But it's a great--
I'm just an enormous fan
of the tooling that's available
if you're writing in G-W-T.
It's just tremendous.
woman: I've got two questions.
Number one, you said
you had three pages
broken down into
three different modules.
Moffat: We've actually got--
yeah, we've got more than that.
We've got seven, I think,
something like that, but yeah.
woman: How do you pass
the GUI state between them?
Would that be through a flow
JavaScript variable or...
Moffat: What we do is...
our pages correspond--
I mean, they all reload.
So like when you go from
the project page
to the process page,
the only information
we actually need to pass
is which process
you're going to.
So we don't need to...
to pass any information
on the client between the pages.
I mean,
the way we could do it
is there's a window.name
hack--is it window.name?
There's a hack you can do
on the window.name
where you can stuff a whole
bunch of information
into the window.name
on one page
and actually pull it out
on the other page
like kilobytes of data.
So that's pretty cool,
but we've never actually
had to do that.
Lundin: I think
the bottom line is that
if you do find that you need
to pass a lot of JavaScript
from sort of one module
to the other,
they really need to be
loaded as one module.
So you really don't
wanna be doing
a whole reload of the page.
Every time you load
a page in GWT,
There's this on module
load method that gets called.
You really would only want
to have that happen once
and then have, you know,
different tabs
or different pages or
whatever you want to call them
as a single module load.
Moffat: Yeah.
woman: Okay.
And number two,
as you mentioned
that your diagram rendering
is done on service side
and client side.
Moffat: Yep.
woman: And according to
heuristics, you decide
whether to pick this up
and start processing.
Why don't you do it both
in parallel
and just go with
the faster one?
Lundin: Well...that's--
that's a very good question.
One of the reason is because
JavaScript is single-threaded,
once you start a layout
on the client,
you can't stop it.
Well, you could if you put in
a lot of breaks
and use incremental commands
and things like that,
but that would be
very complicated.
So for us,
the basic problem was
once we started layout
on the client,
you can't stop it.
And so we could throw off
one on the server,
and if it comes back sooner,
we can't do anything with it.
Moffat: 'Cause we wouldn't
actually be told
until we'd finished the client
that the server had finished.
So we're sort of...
at that point out of luck.
Lundin: There would be ways
to do it, like I said,
if you're using incremental
command and...
splitting your JavaScript
to do lots of little pieces.
But that would actually make
the client even slower,
doing that.
So in the end,
we decided to stick
with the simple approach.
Moffat: I think we're
actually...done, unfortunately.
We can talk later.
Thank you very much, everybody.
Thanks.
[applause]